cómo
vamos
las personas que tienen miedo no pueden
ser artistas hay una rojo una valentía y
una fuerza que son imprescindibles o no
hay obra el arte no es para cobardes y
esta frase es de la gran dramaturga
luisa josefina hernández muchísimas
gracias por estar aquí con nosotros
marina a qué le atribuyes tu éxito
y pues yo creo que a no pensar en él yo
estoy convencida que el éxito no puede
ser un objetivo el éxito en sí mismo no
es nada lo que importa es lo que lo que
está atrás en lo que cuál es tu objetivo
ir hacia el éxito es una consecuencia
pero no sin lugar a dudas no creo que
debe hacer algo que deba estar en la
mira porque es fútil no es nada decía
olivia colman ahora que ganó el premio
'mejor actriz' tú estuviste ahí en la
ceremonia del oscar que todas las
actrices piensan en algún momento en
crear el discurso de agradecimiento
cuando recibes un oscar en el baño puede
ser el shampoo no en el espejo puede ser
el cepillo pero si seguís y te lo
imaginas te en algún momento antes
ansias de la experiencia derrama una vez
más de verdad no no y mucho menos el
oscar y mucho menos ningún
reconocimiento para mí y siempre desde
mi formación estuvo muy claro que un
poco retomando la primera pregunta que
eso jamás podría ser un objetivo porque
entonces estaría yo equivocada
a veces he dicho creo que he dicho
contigo que cuando alguien decide que
quiere ser algo en mi caso actriz tiene
que ser por ser actriz no no por ser
famosa o por ser o por el reconocimiento
que puedas recibir sino por el gozo
profundo que implica hacer lo que amas y
que tu vida se trate de hacer lo que
amas qué papel juega el rigor y la
vocación de una actriz
yo creo que muchísimo muchísimo
yo recuerdo mucho que me decían en la
escuela hay que ser riguroso y no rígido
y que hay una enorme diferencia entre
ser rígido y ser riguroso y yo yo soy
una ferviente creyente de la disciplina
creo que los actores son muy dados a
perderla en un momento dado que hay otro
tipo de profesiones como los bailarines
que no la pueden perder jamás cuentos de
verdad no logran nada
el actor se la tiene que estar
recordando y recordando y recordando y
tiene que ver con muchas cosas con un
modo de vida con cómo alimentas el
espíritu con lo que lees con lo que oyes
con lo que vas a ver de lo que te
alimentas y además de entrenar tu cuerpo
y entrenar tu voz pero sobre todo
entrenar tu intelecto y tu espíritu qué
papel juega la suerte muchísima suerte
no sea muy un papel muy importante
porque en el actor por por ejemplo
hablemos de roma'
la suerte de tener la edad del personaje
que están buscando detener el tipo
físico del personaje que están buscando
de que ese día que hiciste la audición
estaba tú estabas en tu centro y
entonces proyectas te algo en muchas
cosas creo que es una combinación de
disciplina de rigor y de suerte pero con
la suerte pasa como con el éxito no
depende de ti es mejor no pienses en eso
un electricista
nace o se hace muy bien las dos cosas
las dos cosas
pero como me encanta porque regresamos
al mismo tema como no podemos nace que
estaríamos hablando de lo que es el
talento y el talento es algo que no
sabemos ni dónde ir a comprarlo ni cuál
es la receta entonces yo pienso que es
mejor no pensar en él y concentrarse en
lo que uno sí se puede concentrar que es
en hacer lo que puedo que sí que sí
depende de mí lo que hago
una vez regresamos como me formó con
quién estudió con qué qué qué proyectos
me hacen crecer qué proyectos me retan
hay que concentrarse en el hacerse y si
naciste o no mejor ni te lo preguntes yo
tengo que preguntar algo muy particular
después de haber vivido toda esta
experiencia de roma que vaya cuánto
tiempo fue serían dos años
aproximadamente
incluyendo el rodaje si no el tiempo en
espera porque aunque sabes que ya te
puedes desprender de alguna otra manera
del proyecto te tienes que reencontrar
para toda la promoción internas digo una
producción con estas características
han pasado unas semanas de la entrega de
la ceremonia del oscar y cómo evaluaría
la experiencia de steam
la experiencia en su totalidad de roma y
llegando a este último momento que fue
muy sorpresivo y maravilloso por
justamente por inesperado la primera
parte sin lugar a dudas es el rodaje que
fue hace dos años y toda la experiencia
de audicionar para ese personaje que fue
muy distinta a cualquier otra que
hubiera tenido larga también donde me
recuerdo que cuando sabía que podía
tener el personaje que ya estaba
cerquita pues lo que hacía todo el
tiempo era tratar de conservar un estado
del alma que es muy difícil de conseguir
no lo conseguí del todo pero quería
acercarme a ello que se trata el querer
no querer querer no querer algo que
sabes que quieres muchísimo pero tenías
como cómo ir enfocando la mente a
no caer en la ansiedad no sino tratar de
conservar cierta serenidad y finalmente
cuando ya lo tienes entonces pues es
decir tengo que voy a afrontar el reto
que es inmenso y todos los días y un
rodaje de seis meses que no es nada
normal para una película que normalmente
se hacen en seis semanas
que se hace en orden cronológico con un
con actores que están actuando por
primera vez y eres la única actriz que
tiene formación actoral y eso a veces en
realidad juega en tu contra en vez de a
tu favor entonces todos los días yo lo
yo creo que era una experiencia un poco
cn para mí como de un estar en presente
de absoluta concentración
de no soltar nunca el objetivo y así
fueron el rodaje después termina y pasan
dos años en los que regreso a hacer
teatro hago otra vez televisión con
ernesto contreras y de pronto hasta te
olvidas de que eso sucedió y de pronto
llega el momento en donde eso nace se da
a la luz y es y resulta un fenómeno que
no esperabas porque yo sabía que iba a
ser una obra de arte hermosa porque yo
veía lo que alfonso estaba poniendo allí
y el artista que es pero el fenómeno en
el que se convirtió es otro fue otra
experiencia fue otra cosa sí superior
tus expectativas cuando viste la
película que fue en venecia en venecia
en el festival de venecia estaba muy
nerviosa la verdad porque si estaba
viendo por primera vez sí y si me me
pasó algo que no me suele pasar mucho
que como actores normalmente estamos
viéndonos a nosotros y criticando nos
muchísimo
y siempre te odias y acá lo que me pasó
fue que realmente me atrapó más allá de
mí deje de pensar en mí
y me conecto con otras cosas que con las
que trabaje en el rodaje que tenían que
ver con la infancia que tenían que ver
con la memoria remota que tenían que ver
con las pérdidas y los dolores
infantiles con un méxico que ya no
existe y pude ser espectadora que es
raro
héctor mendoza decía que que si el
proceso creativo el proceso artístico no
te transformaba como persona no vale la
pena hacerlo estoy seguro que roma te
cambió mucho
tienes identificado modificaciones y sin
duda creo que como actriz algo que tiene
que ver con la confianza que hay algo
que a veces como actores nos pasa que es
que sabemos que tenemos que hacer una
escena
y que tiene que llegar a cierto nivel
emocional y entonces tienes miedo que
siguiendo nada más los pasos que sabes
que debes seguir que tienen que ver con
la concentración con el ponerse en
situación con el traer al personaje
etcétera tienes miedo de que no pase y
entonces haces cosas demás o empujar una
emoción o prevenir te de artificialmente
y creo que esto es una cosa que el
trabajo con alfonso de puro por completo
y que si tenía que ver absolutamente con
confiar con y que creo que eso es
importantísimo en el actual y en la vida
pues pero confía que ahí estará el
personaje confía que llegará hasta el
lugar lo que tienes que llegar que no
sabes ni siquiera cuál es
espero que todos ustedes quieren saber
cómo la experiencia del llega del oscar
y más desde el punto de una nómina pues
no se parece a nada que me hubiera
imaginado la realidad siempre te
sorprende y nunca es lo que te imaginas
y creo que eso todos lo podemos entender
no crees que este día de tu vida va a
ser súper especial y si lo es pero no de
la manera en la que te habías imaginado
y para mí pues fue como algo que nunca
había realmente ni deseado ni esperado y
si tenía la prerrogativa de disfrutar
cada segundo sabía que era una alfombra
roja muy larga muy difícil donde estás
te están viendo por todas partes
tienes que sostener y lo vemos nervioso
ya este día no estuve muy nerviosa
durante muchos momentos de la promoción
incluso en la alfombra roja de venecia
por ejemplo que fue la primera allí sí
porque era la primera vez porque además
esta es muy glamorosa con mucha
tradición pero los oscares llegaron al
final de una promoción de seis meses
entonces ya todo estaba como aplomado y
también ya sabía que no había nada más
que disfrutarlo porque no había nada más
que hacer y ya si va a terminar y se iba
a terminar y era una despedida y así lo
viví como el gusto profundo
supongo que al día siguiente hay un
sentimiento muy particular y me refiero
a que vives en una situación especial
cargada de energías uno no en un estado
que sólo es el común sí sí da la
sensación como de la caída lo que se
siente después de subirte a la rueda de
la fortuna y ya llegaste abajo no hay
como la caída de la euforia también
donde tienes que
a nivelar cierto sentimiento de una
nostalgia que ya se anticipa
de algo que sabes que va a que fue uno
de los momentos más intensos de tu vida
y que ya ahora es un recuerdo y eso pues
es pues eso la el sentimiento agridulce
que se siente ante la proximidad de algo
que ya se fue para siempre
y ahí finalmente hay que regresar a casa
y hay que regresar tu realidad no a
llevar a tu hijo al colegio pero eso es
muy bonito también para que lo lloramos
mucho porque fueron contábamos hace un
momento la cantidad de vuelos más de 50
vuelos e irte de casa y a mí me gusta
mucho la vida cotidiana me encanta esto
de llevar a mi hijo a la escuela de ir
al súper de estas cosas te adaptas te
dan centro eso es lo que la vida se
trata de eso también y si lo extrañaba y
de pronto pues si volver a eso al final
es es tierra
es lo que te centra es lo que te dice
quién eres es lo que te dice esto es un
gran momento pero la vida se trata de
muchas cosas más que se piensa cuando
estás sentada y mencionan tu nombre
cuando están leyendo las nominadas y
pasan una escena de la película que
estás pensando en ese momento te
recuerdas pues qué gran privilegio que
qué enorme gratitud siento de que a que
me tocó ser parte de algo así no que que
al final es un fenómeno colectivo que
depende del trabajo de muchísimos o sea
para que mi trabajo esté ahí
definitivamente es el trabajo no solo de
alfonso también de eugenio de yelitza
soy parte de una colectividad que suerte
que gratitud porque yo creo que la
gratitud es una actitud muy importante
que hay que cultivar y bueno amigos
marina de tavira regresa a la ciudad de
mexico a estrenar una obra de teatro
titulada the sky light la cual se va a
presentar en un escenario muy íntimo
y supongo que también eso te reconecta
con quien verdaderamente eres y con
quien verdaderamente quieres ser
y tu identidad esté atrás totalmente
totalmente yo yo creo que alguna vez lo
hemos hablado yo siempre digo que yo
estudié teatro no actuación y siempre
quise ser una actriz de teatro
me enamoré de la actuación viendo una
actriz en el escenario y siempre pensé
que esto sería lo único que daría teatro
y la vida pues te va sorprendiendo y hay
que aceptar las cosas que te dan y
tomarlas porque son también pueden ser
maravillosas de esas vueltas de tuerca
pero si el teatro para mí tiene algo muy
especial que es la comparecencia viva
del espectador y del actor creo que eso
es algo que sólo le pertenece al teatro
bueno y por supuesto a la danza y la
ópera ya otras pero hablando
del actor que pertenece al teatro que es
ese momento esa experiencia estética que
sucede entre el actor y el personaje que
es única y que seguramente no es tan
mediática que seguramente no te da tanto
reconocimiento que pero que yo atesoro
como pocas cosas en la vida ahí estaba
mi siguiente pregunta marina finalmente
el teatro tiene el poder de transformar
vidas porque cuando se da porque sabes
que cuesta trabajo lo que se ve el
efecto teatral en un escenario puede ser
tan grande y magnánimo que puede
transformar la vida de algún es de algún
espectador en una sala de mil
exactamente a lo mejor sólo de uno y por
ello la p1 valió la pena porque sin duda
se trata de sí de la transformación de
la conciencia de la persona y es la
persona la única capaz de transformar la
sociedad entonces basta con no no no
está pelada la gran masa es apelar a la
persona y en un mundo en el que vivimos
cada vez más despersonalizado y ahora
mucho más
nos relacionamos más a través de un
aparato que a través de una de una
mirada entonces esto es lo que el teatro
sigue teniendo que sigue siendo un
encuentro que se trata de las personas
no mediadas por nada más que la
experiencia de la vida misma que es ir a
atestiguar lo que somos en el escenario
porque es importante defender y proteger
nuestra cultura nuestro arte hoy en día
aquí en méxico porque si no nos vamos a
morir
espiritualmente y por espiritualmente me
refiero a intelectualmente
lo que somos es decir como humanidad
necesitamos alimentos comer comida que
nos nutre pero estamos otro tipo de
comida que eso es la cultura
ese es el arte no desear un siglo un
dramaturgo mexicano un pueblo sin teatro
es un pueblo sin verdad un pueblo sin
historia entonces un pueblo sin cultura
historia que nos ven que nos vamos a
convertir sin cultura yo no quiero ni
pensar en que en autómatas
de que no ahí está la salvación de la
humanidad
ahí está la posibilidad de la conciencia
de una transformación
ahí está la posibilidad de reconocernos
como personas como seres humanos que
merece respeto cada una por el simple
hecho de que es única e irrepetible
amigos es la última pregunta foto de
esta sesión y es una pregunta que
siempre hago en el programa de taller de
actores profesionales qué consejo le
darías a cualquier joven jovencita que
no se está viendo en estos momentos nos
está escuchando
y que quiere dedicarse a la actuación
pues me gusta cerrar con lo que
empezaste y este es el consejo no
confundir el éxito con con el objetivo
final es ese no sirve este no te va a
llevar a ningún lado ese va a ser más
efímero de lo que de por sí ya es esta
carrera
entonces estás mejor otra cosa porque es
ser actor requiere de muchísima entrega
de muchísima disciplina yo he pasado más
fines de semana dentro de un camerino
que en un fin de semana con mis amigos o
con mi familia de vacaciones o viendo
una película entonces si hay mucho
sacrificio entonces que sea porque
realmente eso es lo que amas porque si
no lo vas a sufrir mucho y vas a estar
facturando que no tienes el éxito
suficiente si lo que necesitas si
quieres de ser famoso
o tener éxito hay otras opciones y más
ahora con todas las posibilidades de las
que las redes sociales te dan entonces
mejor no seas actor porque ser actor es
muy distinto de ser famoso ser famoso
puede ocurrir pero no puede ser el
objetivo
decía matiz la creatividad requiere
valentía tú lo tienes señoras y señores
ya es marina de esta vida
cómo
x